by the time the Stars arrived for the
Oscars the hard work is already done and
that doesn't just mean making the film
there's a whole other industry involved
in getting here
the Quest for Glory begins with the for
your consideration campaigns a publicity
barrage of billboards glad handing and
high-profile interviews with World
leading strategists pulling the strings
it begins before the films have even
made they have a pretty good idea what
their Market is and this is who they're
trying to impress production designer
Dan lamino is one of ten thousand voting
Academy members he's lived through all
manner of Oscar's campaigns they don't
start they've got the marketing people
the publicity people it can be
aggressive because it it's a it's a lot
of money if a picture is nominated and
then wins so these are the 10
shortlisted films voting members can
watch films on this portal and very few
get through all of them so a big
publicity push can be very influential
y'all remember Leslie don't you Helen
Raymond's little girl this was exposed
last month when two Leslie which flunked
at the box office scored a surprise best
actress nomination for Andrea
reisborough thanks to some A-list
support you should be up for everything
you should be winning everything Andrea
risborough this is the I think the
greatest female performance on screen I
have ever seen in my life a number of
celebrities posted on social media about
two Leslie with the same phrase a small
film with the giant heart suggesting
this so-called Grassroots campaign was
something a lot more targeted
well he's for a shock nomination was
seen by some as having shut out black
actors like Danielle deadweiler
and Viola Davis
first is a question of privilege right
because you've got to have very uh
popular friends for something to come
through uh you know to break through the
Zeitgeist so not everyone can do it
secondly I have always thought that
Awards such as these should be based on
Merit not popularity contests
while direct lobbying of Voters is
already banned campaigns can still cost
tens of millions of pounds and the
academy says they are going to look very
hard at the rules around campaigning
before next year's event
but when it comes to Awards season it is
as ever a fight for attention Martha
callner Sky News Hollywood